[Music]
hey you guys time for another matinee
now you knew we could not [ __ ] resist
watching a movie called we just shark
man we put that [ __ ] trailer on and I
saw it [ __ ] I just started [ __ ]
laughs and I was like we got to see this
one yes this one it's okay here's the
weird thing
it's that oh sorry like there's a good
oops so what happened was I guess this
is it's weird because the copy right at
the end says 2017 and when I looked up
and I did a little bit of research about
it I guess it's been like they finished
be like doing it in 2018 but they didn't
release it until 2020 for whatever
reason so it's been sitting on a shelf
somewhere well it probably had to pay
Xbox and you know get it released
probably so I suppose yes and I mean I
guess you can like stream at other
places too we just run it on Xbox and
like I said we were like scrolling
through there and I was like okay well
we definitely have to watch something
called we do shark now I will say and
you will know this from the trailer this
is like not even a low budget this is
like a micro budget yeah I would be
shocked if this cost more than $10,000
tomato and actually I kind of be shocked
if it cost that much right um
it definitely does look like it was shot
with a handheld camera yeah and not like
a professional camera it might have been
shot with a phone I'm not really sure
but so this is the same production
company Wild Eye releasing that also
released it's not the same director or
write or anything but they also released
the infamous vilasa pastor which I have
not seen yet I had to see that one well
although yeah I've been hearing a lot
about that one I mean just that title
alone I kind of have to say that but
it's the same releasing company that did
that one so you kind of know what you're
getting in for the thing about this is
that so the guy that directed it he's
his real name is Brett Kelly but on this
movie he's going under the pseudonym
Scott Patrick for whatever reason he has
also made other movies he has made other
shark movies Jurassic Shark Raiders of
the Lost shark so there was you know
what I mean and also the co-writer of
this movie plays the dad in ouidah shark
yeah now this
movie much as the title suggests it's
basically just about this group of girls
who are like friends
it will young women I guess they're not
really girls but so they're meeting at
this one house like to have a pool party
for whatever reason they're all getting
together for whatever reason and the
first girl that you see who's I can't
remember any the characters names to
forgive me but um she finds a Ouija
board on the beach after feeling
something in the water comes with like
driftwood kind of like yeah kind of like
something out of that one [ __ ]
carpenter because of the fog yeah kind
of like that and you can tell there
there are some like oh ma jizz two other
horror movies in this like jaws
you know there's cuff there was one two
[ __ ] I can't remember now it's movie
Evil Dead or something like that yeah
and like some of the you know some of
the point of view shots are kind of like
Friday the 13th type [ __ ] or any because
you can see shots from like the the
shark and so they all get to this house
there get bored and they decide they're
gonna play with the Ouija board and
hilariously they start asking it
questions and all it will spell out is
hungry and then all of a sudden you see
like this kind of little shark coming
and then like you know as it goes on
like the the titular we just shark
starts attacking people now you get okay
the thing about this that is very
strange to me is that you can tell this
is one of those movies that it's you
know it's supposed to be deliberately
bad I mean obviously the Ouija shark
itself is clearly just like a shark
puppet that they put this kind of like
glow filter on and it's just kind of
like going through the trees it's not in
the water or nothing it's like we're
going around in the woods its eyes just
go [ __ ] to go shark that's why yeah yeah
and and they're trying to kill it and it
makes like a little it's it's funny
because when it like when it eats
somebody sometimes when it eats somebody
like they're you know severed limbs go
flying and there's blood stuff and
sometimes they just kind of wink out of
existence which I thought was a little
weird but whatever I don't know what the
budget was I guess so it's like we only
have so many gorgeous in the graphic
senator actually pretty good there's not
that much of them so they did actually
have the money to do that but the shark
looks like ridiculous but in in they're
suppose to though it's supposed to look
ridiculous and I did laugh every single
time that they showed it I enjoyed the
movie sorry and I did too I did too it's
very funny and it's just kind of like
and I'm and I love the sound effect of a
shark when he's like going after so
because it sounds kind of like Pookie
sounds when she's like eating her treats
offer a little Bowl or whatever it's
like it's like this little kind of
munchies on which I thought was very
funny so you know like I said it's super
super cheap it's only like a location or
two the acting is not good it's like the
special effects are not good and I will
say that even though it's not that long
a movie it's only about an hour and 10
minutes
it doesn't overstay its welcome yeah but
I will say that I wish that they had got
more into the shark action like quicker
because I do feel like the first half
hour or so kind of drags because you're
like hanging around the house with these
girls and you know there's a start
there's a shark coming we usually like
come on like let's let the [ __ ] we
just started get released you know my
take on it my take on it is that you
know there were pros and cons to the
movie yeah all right overall it was
enjoyable movie to watch I mean if you
rent a movie after call Ouija shark
after seeing this trailer okay if you
read that and then give that 1 or 2
stars there's something [ __ ] wrong
with you you should have never bought it
to begin with yeah what do what it was
when you got into it and the trailer
makes it pretty clear like whether than
what you're getting into trailer makes
it very clear what kind of movie this is
as soon as we saw it we started laughing
that's the homie we get some drinks and
it does deliver and what it's supposed
to be it's just an entertaining story
for I don't know maybe young guys or old
guys or whatever it's got girls in it in
bikinis with boobs
usually when you hire girls to do movies
to have boobs the boobs come for free I
guess well but hey it's not like you
leave them at home but precious we would
like to sometime not talking about like
both 1980s bimbo implant type boobs
they're just somethings big boob so you
can tell the dude was a bull lady
they're all regular looking women what's
that kind of like yeah they're already
looking a girl-next-door type yeah yeah
they don't look like they're good little
girls they don't look like [ __ ]
supermodels or right strippers or
anything like that yeah actually they're
just realistic looking yeah yeah just
like I said like the girls nose next
door but and I see you know you knew
what it was when you rented it yeah yeah
I gave it five stars know what I knew
what it was and it did do what it was
supposed to do it had me [ __ ] laugh
and through most of it
every time silly man seeing the shark
never got old
yeah I was like the shark is ridiculous
every single scene with the shark even
though you knew it was coming and even
though you knew what it looked like I
laughed every single [ __ ] time that
yeah acting was it wasn't bad but it was
just serviceable amateurism serviceable
it depend on which actor you were
talking about some we're better than
others but it didn't matter you knew
what this movie was when you came out I
get kind of mad I heard some other guys
review it and I'm like why the [ __ ] did
you rent it the trailer showed you what
this was do you know what though the
only criticism because here's here's the
thing making a movie is a really
difficult proposition so anyone that has
like the balls to and like I totally
respect the game it's like if you want
to make like a ridiculous movie called
ouija shark and you want to make it like
intentionally bad you just go for it
it's like it was a funny [ __ ] movie
the only criticism I would make about it
is that I wish they had leaned harder
into yeah it needed to be crazier it
needed to be crazier like and the thing
is it's it had a crazy premise and the
shark was funny but it's like it seems
like it didn't get really batshit until
near the end and we were thinking about
like all of these possibilities that
they could have done and maybe like
because budgetary constraints I guess
they couldn't do some of the [ __ ] we
thought of they should have called me
how could it cause
first thing those if you have a ghost
shark that comes through a [ __ ] Ouija
board you also have to have [ __ ]
shark possession we're going to see them
right
yes to buy a shark yeah see that would
have been hilarious and then you then go
out and do [ __ ] and that wouldn't cost
anything extra yeah cuz you can stab
just a trifle go out and act like if you
got a person possessed by asscher-cut in
that unless you got to have a shark sysm
yeah exactly
which now you metal you got at least you
can bring in a priest to exorcise a
shark
charge this isn't there's all kinds of
[ __ ] you could have done with this and
the exorcism aim should be father Quint
some of this [ __ ] takes place in the
spirit realm where they're fighting the
shark what was that was the funniest
yeah well this should have been all
kinds of [ __ ] in the spirit realm I mean
[ __ ] that's the happy hunting ground
there should have been Indians and [ __ ]
he's fighting it [ __ ] demons fighting
it or fight alongside of it if you're in
the spirit realm [ __ ] put angels in
there there's all kinds of [ __ ] you
could have done with that that probably
wouldn't cost much more I mean you'd
have gotten crazy with it um so in a way
that I thought the movie was reserved
see that's what that's the criticism
that I had it's like it wasn't so much
that you know that it's a dumb movie or
that it was bad or anything because
that's what they intended it to be it's
supposed to be like a dumb bad movie
which you know cool and I knew I should
be entertaining - yeah yeah and I was
entertained I just wished that they had
gone farther with the premise because
that's a great premise yeah it's
ridiculous I and I could have made a
[ __ ] I wish they would have amped that
ridiculousness up
I mean because some of the scenes like
with the girl's dad and he's like in the
spirit world like fighting the shark at
all is that I mean that was so [ __ ]
funny that I wish they had done more of
that this movie okay
it's kind of like an asylum flick
alright yeah like asylum studios I think
it's called Sam's dude yeah it's the
ones that make all those ripoffs yeah
but the thing is though is that compared
to this Asylum is making tentpole foot
flicks
yeah but means a lot yeah so
to compensate for your for your budget
you got to come up with some crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes it has to be like
insane and and it I would have enjoyed
it a lot more I think the first 20
minutes of it was kinda a little bit
slow it was yeah I would have kind of
cut a lot of that out I wouldn't have
bothered too much of trying to make
characters just have people doing [ __ ]
yeah you can figure out who they are
whether you really don't have to even
know who the characters are yeah you
just want them to get even by the ghost
yeah but all in all for what we paid to
rent it I think was 399 I had it yeah I
did too
I laughed at it and I laughed with it it
was trolling the movies trolling yeah
yeah I mean it's obviously trolling yeah
yeah it's obviously supposed to just be
like a spoof because here's the thing
with the budget that they had and
considering the very few like gore
effects that they had in it like with
the severed arm and like some of the
attacks and stuff those looked really
good so had they wanted to do a better
looking shark they I feel like they
probably could have it would have been
shittier though right so I feel like
they on purpose said well you know we
don't want like a shitty CGI shark
necessarily that just looks like a
computer-generated shark so it's like
let's just make it like look super super
bad and it looked like something if
you're if you're old enough to remember
it looked like something out of the
[ __ ] hole Sid Marty Krofft Land of
the Lost yeah yeah that's what that's
about what looked like damn that [ __ ]
what was the name of that dinosaur the
[ __ ] one that would pull the [ __ ]
car was he dopey dopey yeah look at the
shark was dopey there's blue
if Dewey was glowing yeah yeah yeah yeah
because I mean the shark was clearly
like a puppet and it was just kind of
like you know he was like chomping his
little rubber TV and I baby like I made
a little glowy thing and I'm not sure I
would have shown the shark in the
trailer yeah because they showed the
shark of the trailer yeah and I think I
would have saved the shark to the
[ __ ] final end and I would have had
more than just a shark I would have made
like some angels and demons and [ __ ]
also to fight it in spirit I don't think
it would cost much more yeah you know so
my main complaint was that if you're
gonna do this it's gotta be
[ __ ] crazy that's what I made just go
balls to the wall man cuz it's it's a
great premise like I said it's very
funny because I was reading what I was
doing research before we recorded this I
was reading one website review of this
on culture crypt and the guy that wrote
the review was like I don't know if I
had anything to do with this or not but
he's like I posted on Twitter back in
2017 or 2018 he's like I think at this
point horror movies have reached peak we
Jia and peek shark because it's just
like there's so many like shitty Weejun
movies and so many shitty shark movies
and he made the joke it's like I expect
Asylum movies to come out one day with
wheat with which a shark and he's like
so I was very surprised to see that so
what it actually made it you know what
it mean so he's like I don't know if I
was responsible for that I think that's
probably giving me too much credit it is
kind of set up well there could be a
ouija shark
we just shark - or vici shark the
possession yeah it's not a shark The
Exorcism sharks are just no exorcism I
think that's what they should call it if
anybody's like watching this seriously
call me alright the [ __ ] like this the
sheikah rice story is an actual horror
writer and we'll put some funny [ __ ]
all right screenplay shark sister I have
to say though it's like this kind of
[ __ ] happens on an airplane Matt yeah
well yeah just like 60,000 he exactly
happens no maybe in a hot-air balloon or
it happens on the Hindenburg Hindenburg
- if you have to get that [ __ ] crazy
that's what I mean that would be
hilarious right that would be hilarious
the best silent movie and I believe it
was in the silent movie I remember it
was actually Nazis at the center of the
earth yeah I think that was an asylum
maybe they make some noise I think it
was asylum yeah you know if the makers
of this film are listening in to this
review I would suggest watch him Nazis
at the center of the earth okay a lot
can be learned from that film that is a
[ __ ] piece of it's a masterpiece
Nazi sci-fi horror yeah [ __ ] they
just nailed it and that [ __ ] just as
it unfolds it just keeps doubling down
on the [ __ ] is
it's just taking the piss out of you
yeah every [ __ ] time that story more
is revealed in that story and at the end
you find out it's a documentary it was
it was all true
I believe it was all - every word of it
it sure is all true but yeah when I saw
it I was like that should happen yeah I
was convinced watching this moot
watching we just shark it reminded me of
if you guys um I don't know if you guys
cuz cuz you guys know a big like a
Mystery Science Theater fan so when they
did the new seasons when they did mst3k
the return on Netflix like season 11 one
of the episodes which was Avalanche one
of those 70s disaster movies with Mia
Farrow one of the skits that the that
the that Jonah and the bots did in the
middle was they were coming up with a
whole bunch of like Asylum style horror
movie titles and they wanted to like
have them all you know listed there like
so nobody can steal these because these
are our ideas you know what I mean so
this big long-running list and it's like
I want I was like oh man somebody should
write all those down for posterity and
somebody on reddit did and funnily
enough one of the ones that they had on
there this came out in 2017 I think 2016
2017 one of them was ghost Orca so you
know they might have been watching but I
mean there were some [ __ ] great ones
like I wrote them all down because some
were so [ __ ] funny like pugs slide
and brunch - puss and Narwhal hrus
arctic terror just want NATO Eagle Soros
American Frightmare clam erodes I like
that one um let me see Willy Klamath
rabbit it's a pug slide - the Pug inning
cancer Kay know the streptococcus
spaniel that was a good one also but
yeah it's like there's this big [ __ ]
list did somebody on the reddit came up
adobe flash flood I like that one -
franken ferret
rikki-tikki tarantula skunk bucket so
you know what I mean so it's they
probably would not mind if you wanted to
steal some of these and I would be very
shocked if one of these didn't become an
actual movie Sunday if it isn't already
so like I said so it's one of them was
ghost Orca they could have got the idea
from there - they're like hey historic a
ghost shark here we go we're making we'd
a shark but yeah so
when it comes to this movie if yeah I
mean if you rent this movie you got any
[ __ ] complain about I don't
understand it after see after just
hearing that title and watching that
trailer
if you press watch and rent that thing
you guys not have any [ __ ] complain
about if you've gotten that far you know
I mean through the vetting process you
just don't have the right to [ __ ]
give that [ __ ] one star I knew what it
was when you probably thought movies
like this almost like immune to the star
system yes it's either gonna be you're
either gonna dig it like for being like
a good bad movie or like a bad
intentionally bad movie or you're not
well one guy not kind of reviewed this
seriously you know their nose was just
like why are you reviewing that movie
that way yeah I mean it's it's a
competently shot movie it's not it's not
bad the way it was shot is you know I
mean I don't think I could shoot a movie
that well yeah I mean it's competent
it's amateurish but it's not like it's
watchable oh yeah I mean this is [ __ ]
much better than a lot of the [ __ ]
schlock movies that came out with
seventies in the 80s I mean you they
really [ __ ] a movies up back then this
is head and shoulders of a well because
you Pirlo back then even to make a movie
you actually needed like decent
equipment yeah now you don't really need
I mean you could shoot it on a phone and
it's like it won't look like the [ __ ]
Marvel movies but it'll look it'll look
watch it did it'll look better than it
would have back in the seventies so yeah
an editing process is a lot easier to do
now and you know to worry about footage
it's just data yeah you don't have to
worry about big ol long footage of film
and [ __ ] spice and [ __ ] and buying
film cans and [ __ ] yeah so so it's a lot
cheaper you can a low-budget movie can
actually turn out to be a lot more
watchful so now I'm kind of like
wondering it see cuz apparently I mean
these this group of people this is not
the only movie that they've made the
actors that were in this I believe most
of it was this was their only movie or
the a couple of them were in some of
this guy's other movies like I said
heated Raiders of the Lost shark which
yeah we probably have to say that I
would [ __ ] also shy away from any kind
of lengthy dialogue if you're making a
movie like this you don't need to know
much just show [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah just so
crazy [ __ ] you know I you know nobody's
really gives a [ __ ]
characters it's just what's happening
yeah you're just being lined up to be
eaten but yeah the Zayn here it is you
don't mean the better yeah like this
just come up with just the craziest [ __ ]
you can imagine doing stuff like there's
you know extended scenes of [ __ ] the
bunch of dialogue it's just it just bogs
the movie down you know yeah like I said
that was the only thing that kind of
bothered me was that the first half you
know the first 30 minutes was kind of
slow cuz you could tell they were trying
to pad out the runtime cuz like I said
it's a pretty short movie it's only an
hour and 10 minutes you can tell they're
trying to Pat it out because there's
really long scenes of like just people
walking through the woods or you know
sitting around by the pool or something
like that so you could tell they're
trying to try to get another 15 minutes
right so it's like that's kind of the
only thing it's like if it has to be a
short film you could probably make it a
short film you know if if you feel like
you're you know straining to like well
fill it up with content but you know had
they done some more stuff in the spirit
world and gotten crazier and had a
[ __ ] you know an exorcism and had it
had you know all that could have you
could have gained it in the 15 minutes
of that and I don't yeah I don't think
it would have cost much more to do that
you know I mean it's just different
material yeah you know but just it just
wasn't in the script I didn't think of
it I guess yeah but I thought this like
I said it's 399 if you rent it if you
went as far as to rent named Britney
probably abused just get drunk and watch
this yes you know it's funny they're
just telling you a story
fine go sharks be good yeah so uh check
it out on whatever streaming platform if
you're into it you know
you